It's like no other beverage on the planet.
Wow! You are earning your name as Sake Dendoshi, Nihonshu Dendoshi.
You are clearly proselytizing me.
That is what I'm trying to do.
What I mean, it's coming out of a pure again, a passion for it.
So, do you think you're making a dent?
A dent?
Are you changing?
Obviously, you're changing out of how to tend to the foreigners and media columns...
Yes, and because I aim for the distribution industry,...
...they make dents too.
Okay.
But here, let me add this,...
...if the sake booze of Japan,...
...the sake booze, we're not making such good stuff,...
...then I have nothing to talk about.
Wow, so you're a big fan.
You're a fan as well as...
Oh absolutely, yeah. I couldn't do this if I wasn't a fan.
It's not to the point where I would criticize you.
Although there's just so much left to be understood.
So much that in other words, sake isn't in some level where you can start criticizing it.